[Musica]
[Applauso]
fino a poco più di un secolo fa
milioni di persone morivano a causa di
malattie infettive ti prendevi il tifo o
la peste potevi solo sperare di vivere
poi fortunatamente sono stati scoperti
gli antibiotici
i vaccini e molte di queste malattie
sono state debellate con quanto meno ci
sono diventate incurabile questa è un
esempio di una rivoluzione in ambito
medico e come uno scalino un salto
quantico
un altro esempio potrebbe essere quello
del trapianto degli organi
se ci pensate fino a soltanto 50 anni fa
se per caso per sfortuna insomma il
vostro cuore non batteva più così bene
ancora una volta non c'era granché da
fare bisogna solo sperare di vivere il
più a lungo possibile ma grazie alle
prime scoperte nell'ambito dei trapianti
la tiroide e reni stiamo parlando i
primi del 900 e poi grazie alla scoperta
della ciclosporina che serve a ridurre o
abbattere il rigetto
sappiamo che dagli anni 70 in poi è
possibile per tentare gli alpini e
quindi salvare delle vite
la rivoluzione in ambito medico che sta
avvenendo proprio in questi anni e di
qui lo voglio parlare oggi è quella che
riguarda le cellule staminali se
pensiamo a quali malattie oggi non
abbiamo una cura gran parte di esse sono
accomunate da un aspetto peculiare
alcune cellule di un certo organismo e
di un certo tessuto organo scusate e
muoiono e perciò quell'ora non funziona
più bene
pensate ad esempio a da malattie neuro
degenerative e alcuni specifici neuroni
del cervello
iniziano a morire e cervello non
funziona più bene
capite che di fronte a questo tipo di
problema l'approccio diciamo
farmacologico non è spesso percorribile
perché perché chiaramente già morte non
c'è più un bersaglio su cui agire quel
farmaco è chiaramente capite che
trapianto dell'intero organo un
trapianto di cervello non è diciamo
tecnicamente eticamente percorribile
come strada anche se quelle volte
qualcuno magari se fa un po arrabbiare
sia esso politico di turno non ci
piacerebbe ma non si può scherzi a parte
cosa che si può fare se si ragionato
imposto alla fine è che qualche cellule
del cervello che è molto bella
basterebbe sostituire solo quelle questa
è una ottima intuizione di fatto ed è
quello che stiamo cercando di fare
ovviamente però stiamo solo spostando un
pochettino il problema perché questi
neuroni sani dove andremo a prendere ed
è qui che entrano delle cellule
staminali cioè le cellule staminale ci
permettono di ottenere ad esempio il
neurone sarà niente che cosa sono le
serio staminali sono delle cellule
caratterizzato dalla capacità di
moltiplicarsi di dare dare origine a
altre cellule staminali identiche alla
madre ma anche di specializzarsi c
andare via da via via origine a cellule
che sono in grado di svolgere funzioni
diverse
allora un esempio molto chiaro ad
esempio è quello della pelle
sapete che la pelle è un organo e
relativamente complesso ha un
rivestimento di cheratina che ci
protegge ma anche i peli ai prodotti da
ovviamente i follicoli o le ghiandole
sebacee spesso quasi tutti avrete una
volta meno sperimentato il fatto che ci
facciamo un taglietto sulla pelle e nel
giro di tre quattro giorni per questa
ferita via e richiusa
ecco quello che di fatto succede è che
le cellule staminali della pelle che
risiedono impari in parte diciamo alla
base dello strato più esterno la pelle
chiamato epidermide oppure proprio
livello dei bulbi piliferi le cellule
staminali in seguito a un danno si
attivano con i si moltiplicano sarà la
prima cosa che diceva e poi migrano nel
sito del danno e lì si differenzieranno
e andando ricostruire quel pezzo di
tessuto che è venuto a mancare
pensate che proprio perché adesso
abbiamo capito come funzionano queste
cellule
possiamo prendere una piccola biopsia e
scarne e cellule staminali della pelle
di di un paziente espanderla in
laboratorio quello che vedete è un
foglio di epidermide che è stato
cresciuto in laboratorio quindi nel caso
delle grandi ustioni ad esempio questa è
diventata una pratica clinica
cioè possiamo prendere la biopsia e poi
aldo trapiantarle questi fogli di
epidermide sana ok questa è
un'applicazione diciamo per così dire
recente attualmente dell'ultimo decennio
delle cellule staminali ma pensate cioè
un applicazione del cellule staminali
che ormai è assolutamente in tutti gli
ospedali quindi è terapia con cellule
staminali ed esiste funziona da 40 anni
questa è un'affermazione forte e allora
alzi la mano chi mi crede mi piace
questo è un pubblico scettico e fate
bene non credete a qualcuno solo perché
ha la giacca microfono in questo caso
sbagliate però perché mi stavo riferendo
al trapianto di midollo osseo che tutti
sapete essere una realtà e ai di fatto
un trapianto di cellule staminali del
sangue del midollo osseo che sapete quel
tessuto molle all'interno delle ossa
cave semmai avete mangiato un osso buco
sapete di cosa sto parlando
ecco nel midollo osseo ci sono le
staminali del sangue
infatti qui trapianti servono a curare i
marchi nel sangue
ad esempio sapete che uno dei principali
componenti del sangue sono i globuli
rossi che servono a portare in giro
l'ossigeno a tutti gli organi quindi una
funzione fondamentale per la vita
ecco così globuli rossi se noi guardiamo
al microscopio appaiono più o meno così
non proprio così appaiono come dei buffi
chalmé ciambelloni immagine microscopio
elettronico che portano un punto in giro
il sangue dei tessuti
se però lo sventurato paziente
all'anemia falciforme i suoi libri rossi
avranno quella forma tipicamente a
farcela che da qui il nome e quindi non
potranno più svolgere questa funzione
che ripeto è basilare per la vita quello
che si fa è prenderle il midollo osseo
di un donatore sano e il trapiantando la
col midollo osseo contiene le staminali
del sangue sane che faranno dei globuli
rossi sani come quelli che vedete alla
vostra sinistra allora gli ha fatto due
esempi di terapia con cellule staminali
che noi chiamiamo anche terapia
cellulare e il concetto di base è sempre
un po lo stesso cioè abbia una cellula
malata come potete vedere rappresentata
da sorriso un po triste ma insomma le
celluline poi noi prendiamo la staminale
che invece è sana quindi è felice e
sorride e con la staminale sala possiamo
fare le cellule differenziate sane che
andando a rimpiazzare quelle che ho sono
malate ormai sono morte gli esempi che
vi ho portato sono ovviamente di organi
che sono facilmente accessibili e falsi
intervenire sul sangue e faccia
intervenire sulla pelle è più complesso
intervenire nel cervello ma questo non
vuol dire che sia impossibile quindi
sicuramente con gli sforzi della
comunità scientifica quindi intendo
biologi medici e ingegneri sicuramente
credo che questo tipo di strada darà e
deve dare speranza a molti malati di
oggi
finora vi ho parlato del presente di
quello che è stato
che cosa penso che ci riserverà
l'immediato futuro
ho deciso di per questa parte di parlare
di infertilità sapete che infertilità
significa semplicemente con la coppia
non può avere dei figli
una delle cause può essere che non ci
sia una produzione di gameti non vengono
prodotti spermatozoi e ovociti fosse
vengono prodotti non sono funzionali ora
e qualcuno di voi potrebbe pensare che
questo non sia un argomento non sia una
condizione che mette diciamo a
repentaglio la vita di nessuno
insomma persone può essere mio fertile
sala chiaramente mette repentaglio però
noi come specie chiaramente non penso
che se vogliamo estinguere troppo presto
e penso anche io credo io ovviamente che
una coppia persona abbia ovviamente il
diritto di avere dei figli devono essere
aiutati ora la scoperta di cui voglio
parlare che è proprio una cosa è
recentissima di un gruppo di gruppo
giapponese peraltro in cosa consiste è
possibile prendere un topolino una
topolina in questo caso è da questo
topolino e ottenere delle cellule
staminali particolari che possono essere
espanse quindi in laboratorio in vitro
che da esse ottenere degli ovociti che
sono perfettamente maturi e funzionali
sono proprio come gli ovociti che le
semi e la nostra specie insomma maturano
in un radi 1 una volta al mese
questi voci che sono stati fecondati in
vitro prendendo gli spermatozoi
ottenendo degli embrioni cindy top a
questi poi mediante una semplice
procedura chirurgica vengono trasferite
all'interno di una topolina che
chiamiamo madre surrogata quindi si
pianteranno nel suo utero e daranno in
meno di un mese nel loro caso dalla vita
a questi topolini buffi che vedete se ci
pensate se mi chiedete chi è il padre di
questi topolini buffet è il topolino
maschio che volente o nolente ha
contribuito gli spermatozoi
se mi chiedete chi è la madre di questi
topolini potrebbe essere la topolina di
partenza da cui però di fatto sono stata
fatta una piccola biopsia poi non ha più
partecipato a questo questo esperimento
per così dire o forse la madre surrogata
o forse l'operatore o con l'operatrice
cioè licenziato che ha condotto questa
procedura dall'inizio alla fine forse
lui io la chiamo la mano
ecco vedete e conoscete sicuramente
l'espressione latina mater semper certa
est
inizia a fare un po di un po di acqua da
tutte le parti questa espressione allora
scherza e parte di fronte a questo tipo
di scoperte io tendo a vedere due
reazioni c'è chi ovviamente dice questo
esilissima quindi c'è il fascino
l'entusiasmo perché è facile capire che
questo potrebbe risolvere molti problemi
di fertilità
ma c'è anche il timore o addirittura
l'indignazione perché chissà a quali
aberrazioni potremmo arrivare di questo
passo anche l'indignazione nel senso
questa la materia su cui non si dovrebbe
fare ricerca che questa è la vita allora
ovviamente non salve che vi dica qual è
di due ovviamente il mio punto di vista
insomma è il mio mestiere sarebbe strano
la seconda ma mi piace solo ricordare
che probabilmente nel secolo scorso
quando si è iniziato a parlare di
trapianti di organi ci sarà chi ha
risposto con entusiasmo dicendo
salveremo molte vite e sarà chi avrà
pensato che nel giro di pochi anni
saremo tutti diventati dei frankenstein
o il braccio per sbanca da vere e
l'occhio è preso anche se dove ok
in conclusione capite che le scoperte
relative alle cellule staminali hanno la
capacità di indurre e forti emozioni che
possono essere l'entusiasmo il timore o
la speranza
capite che hanno già dimostrato in
alcuni casi di poter cambiare
completamente le regole del gioco e io
credo che possano finalmente dagli
strumenti per risolvere per la prima
volta alcuni problemi di salute
attualmente irrisolte e per questi
motivi che io credo che le cellule
staminali siano rivoluzione medica del
presente
[Applauso]